former president Trump just arriving at
Trump Tower leaving Court in New York
City after showing up for the first day
in his civil fraud trial we're going to
have much more on that in just a minute
but first was it a stunt to shut down
the government or is this Progressive
lawmaker just plain stupid
Capitol Police are investigating
Congressman Jamal Bowman after the New
York Democrat yanked a fire alarm right
before the house was about to vote on a
bill to avert a government shutdown
Homan says there was no ill intent it
was just an embarrassing mistake you see
he was rushing to get to a vote and then
came to this door that's normally open
but it was locked a little strange given
that these doors have signs on them that
say emergency exit only but okay
so he did what any of us would have done
and decided to pull the bright red alarm
that's clearly marked with the word fire
Bowman seems to be very confused on why
people are making such a big deal out of
this
are you still stand by your statement
that uh pulling the fire alarm was an
accident
you know I don't know why this has
gotten so much attention I was literally
just in a rush to go vote man that's all
it was are you afraid of any
repercussions either from leadership or
from Legally I mean listen not take
responsibility for what I did you know
but like I said I was in a rush to go
vote but hey the law is the law Bowman
could face more than 30 years behind
bars for the fire alarm pull
AOC in the liberal media coming to his
defense and somehow found a way to blame
Republicans for it
they're fire filing a motion of to expel
a member who in a moment of panic was
trying to escape a vestibule give me a
break there was a mention of Jamal
Bowman Congressman um Jamal Bowman and
the pulling of some sort of fire alarm
just to clarify some things on that
because I know there was
um likely some folks kind of scratching
their heads wondering what it was they
were asking
um speaker McCarthy about that's real
serious and frankly reeks of the sort of
stunts that you know Republicans try to
try to pull sometimes and don't be like
Republicans the Republicans want to make
this uh they want they want to kind of
see how far they can they can run the
trail on this year so we've not heard
the last about uh fire alarm gate uh
from this weekend and our very own peter
ducey's asking if the White House knows
anything about fire marshal Bowman when
President Bai never tried to get out of
a meeting by pulling a fire alarm
are you talking about something
specifically uh Democratic member of
Congress pulled a fire alarm around a
series of boats no fire is that
appropriate what I can tell you is uh
I'm not talking to spoken to the
president about this uh and so just not
going just not going to comment and
she's not gonna come all right Jessica
is Bowman dumb or lying
that's not a very nice choice to have to
me I'm gonna go with the nicest version
of dumb then because I don't think that
he's lying about this first of all this
wasn't the building that the vote was
occurring in in the first place why he
would be trying to stall a vote that all
of the Democrats were voting for was
going to pass over while mainly doesn't
really add up the Capitol Police have
released a statement which seems to
affirm that he tried to open the door
first and I do think the sign on the
door which says like Push the door and
then the alarm will sound for 30 seconds
or whatever it is is a bit confusing but
obviously he should know better he was
also a principal before he became a
congressman he knows about fire safety
that's confusing
push until alarm sounds for three
seconds drawers will unlock in 30
seconds if it's an emergency
don't touch it
the really bad part though is the uh
Nazi statement that came out from his
team so they sent around first to
lawmakers but then it got leaked to the
press that the focus shouldn't be on
Congressman Bowman's actions but the
Nazi Republicans blah blah blah he has
issued a statement saying he doesn't
think that word should be used Etc but
now of course it's going to get everyone
hyped up is it going anywhere no you
need two-thirds of the house to vote to
expel him that's obviously not happening
but it was a weird aside when I saw it
show up on Twitter I was like is this a
real thing yeah I mean it was a real
thing judge because the Democrats were
trying to stall and read whatever bill
was about to come well there's no
question and I disagree with my
colleague on the left when she says why
would he want to stall the vote I'll
tell you why because the day before he
tried to stall it by pulling a fire
alarm and he certainly knows full well
what happens when you pull a fire alarm
because this is cool School principal he
had many fire drills with those kids
okay he actually texts the day before
Republican mathematics is causing
catastrophic shutdown that will force
millions of working people to go without
pay or life-saving benefits and calling
it fiscal responsibility as he condemned
the Republicans they wanted to blame the
Republicans for a shutdown they wanted
this to happen that's why the Kentucky
Resolution that's why that's why he
wanted to slow it down and even the New
York Post an effort to sabotage budget
negotiations by pulling a fire alarm in
the house building his disruption
occurred just as a Democrat leaders in
Congress were stalling for time this is
a concerted effort and let me tell you
when the defend when the when the
defendants when the Democrats criticized
the Republicans for something that they
themselves did it just shows you how out
of touch they are and you know why what
the sign on that door says emergency
exit only he's a congressman he knows
how to go through the tunnels from one
building to the next everybody's who's
in Washington knows that they didn't
want the bill they wanted to blame
Republicans and by the way it's not just
the 30 years that you talk about uh in
D.C faces six months for a violation of
the fire alarm poll 30 years Greg I
don't think he should serve time uh
every single year there is I wouldn't
dismiss the calling Republicans Nazis so
lightly because
if you don't this has always been part
of the strategy if you call somebody
Hitler or you call somebody a Nazi why
wouldn't you sabotage a vote why
wouldn't you rig an election why
wouldn't you create a Witch Hunt against
the person that you've been calling
Hitler so they call them Nazis to
justify this Behavior anything is
possible no question he tried to
interrupt a government official business
this is probably the worst deliberate
act since 9 11. uh the question is uh
does he go to prison it's for how long
he was trying to initiate an
Insurrection on his own and he should be
treated just like the January Sixers
which gets to my amazing comparison when
you think about the extreme wacky
participants of what happened on January
6th The Nutty conspiracists the Q Anon
suckers the misguided Pirates
they weren't a sitting Congressman you
know and that's the key difference in
these parties on the right the freaks
aren't in power on the left the freaks
are in power and if you want proof
compare how they create their own
conspiracies the conspiracy's Origins on
the right they Bubble Up from chat rooms
they Bubble Up from uh Reddit or uh
nobodies in forums in chat rooms right
and they're crazy and they don't really
go anywhere but on the left it's their
conspiracies are created by a cabal of
Institutions right and politicians who
created the steel dossier that didn't
come from a q Anon that came from
Hillary right the Russian collusion uh
suppressing uh Hunter's laptop these
were all done by professionals people
that are high up in the party so on the
right the nuts remain nuts on the left
the nuts become elevated and they end up
running the country I think we should be
really really frightened by that this
dude has to face the same consequences
he should not be you know he should be
expelled that's what you would do in his
school as a principal you would expel a
student for pulling that so he should
not be he should go to jail when I
pulled alarms in high school I was
usually suspended yeah the third time I
think was the expulsion wait you did
this regularly all the time
test if there was a test that I didn't
study I mean of course I'm kidding okay
good I'm trying to save you of course
Martha what do you think should happen
here well if the original question was
is he dumb or is he lying I think that
the proper course for him you know the
only thing that could have made him look
better in this situation is if he said
you're damn right I pulled the alarm and
you know why because I want to read the
bill right I want to pause the process
so that might have been one course of
action that he could have taken honesty
sometimes could be very helpful if you
wonder why Congress has a 19 approval
rating right just take a look at Jamal
Bowman and the principal who pulls the
fire alarm take a look at fetterman and
his sweats take a look at bobert and the
groping take a look at Santos and the
lying I mean you wonder why people do
not have respect for this body
people who are drunk pull fire alarms
usually around last call yeah if they or
if they get thrown out of a bar or if
they don't have money to pay the bill
exactly yeah
he might have been drunk
let's drug test him also yes
I mean I was
just meant like this Barry Loudermilk
from Georgia who was giving tours to
January 6 insurrectionists the day
before oh I get it all right so
everything I say is confinement that was
the bumps Jessica
and it's been debunked I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now